timeouts boston just used their last
timeout
here we go tatum giannis switches on to
him
potato banana kumpo the superstar step
back three on the way
oh it banks in jason
tatum puts boston on top
with a window three how about that
[Applause]
a prayer answer tatum over giannis
and boston by two with .4 seconds
remaining
turned into a one-on-one game the best
defender on the bucks
goes up against the best offensive
player on boston
taking their time getting the best shot
available
his patented move we've seen tatum do
that in and out left dribble
step back to the left angle
and yeah the bank's open you can act
like you meant to hit that off the glass
the words of paul pierce i didn't call
glass
i called gang over the defensive player
of the year
and chris you talk about defined roles
tatum's shot as tough as it was
he knocks it down he scored seven of the
last nine
boston points still a chance here for
milwaukee remember the timeouts
remaining can advance the ball there's
point four
left and down two
time for a catch and shoot here chris
but it's got to be quick
it can be quick but this is what you
don't want to lose you do not want a
back screener coming up to get a shooter
both men going to the shooter in the
easy alley-oop at the basket
we've seen this play many times right
now anthony cooper
passing the ball in
[Music]
i remember chris middleton hit a big
shot here in a playoff game to force
overtime
that was back in 2018 robert williams
was on the floor
for boston brad stevens changes his mind
now he's going to bring
team back on i do wonder why anthony
cooper is inbounding the ball
it seems like he should be in the play
closest to the basket one of the best
finishers in the game
got to be a catch and shoot mike
buttonholzer wants to tie it up maybe he
was all
a wooden duck chris maybe it's all a
decoy he had a timeout in his pocket
and budenholzer takes it and now we'll
draw one up
and the final point for left in this one
what a game
what a way to start the year for these
two teams great play and called that
time
lopez was under the basket looking as if
hey
throw it up i can tip it in that time
as you see right here look at lopez act
like he's going to pick and then what
does he do
ducks right in saying wait a minute
throw it up to me
that's the kubo taking his time but
again just because he's the
inbound doesn't mean that lopez can't
inbound and do the same thing and put
anthony cooper in those things
[Applause]
not there going up top giannis and a
foul
no basket it was a whistle prior to
against boston
[Applause]
this could mean free throws of
possession
let's sort this out and see where the
foul was called they'll certainly go to
review
the same exact play as before
the same play you just put a different
man in a different position
that's why you do want to pay attention
to the first
stance of what they're doing all they
did was move a man out to the corner
so that after cuckoo did not have
it triggers an automatic replay for time
and i could argue anthony cooper on that
play
actually held thompson having been in
this position
many times before with this lobby at the
end of games fouls called prior to the
clock
going to zero before there was a touch
nick booker the official who made that
call
everybody keeping an eye on that video
board the officials
are reviewing this one
clock doesn't move no touch whistle was
blown i believe
prior to
we'll get an explanation shortly from
the officials you can see how close the
file occurred
before the ball was legally touched the
game clock's reset to four tenths
giannis shoots two free throws for the
lineup
wow and that's worse case scenario for
boston
that's what they were afraid of and now
chris how it turns
anita kupo a chance to tie it with free
throws
va the worst case scenario is if he
would have made the shot
you want giannis at the line if you're
the opposing team as opposed to dunking
on you
you want to see if he can knock these
two free folks down later
he's made four in a row at the line
and giannis knocks down the first clutch
free throw
by anna nakumpo
what a huge pawn at the end of this game
oh it comes up short and that's it the
ball was
touched the game is over another couple
misses a chance to tie it and the boston
celtics win the opener at td garden
tonight
[Applause]
122-121 tatum's three-pointer
is a game winner
oh the greek freak will be crushed
leaving a free throw short to tie it
chris well as i said the worst case
scenario on that is for him to dunk on
you and get an automatic two points
we've seen first of all he is the
reigning mvp you better put
some respect on his name however when it
comes to free throws and three-pointers
you'll be happy to let the reigning mvp
take those shots
and let the chips fall where they make
because you can't stop him
in any other part of the game donald
have made five consecutive free throws
until that mess he ends up